hey Doug Walker here we're doing a video
addressing why our videos have only been
15 minutes here on YouTube and as some
of you might have noticed if you're
keeping an eye on YouTube recently uh a
lot of youtubers some very well-known
some not so well known have suddenly
either been having their channels
deleted or they've been having their
monetization taken away that means that
they can't get paid for the videos that
they're putting up and a lot of them are
saying that they're not getting answers
why this just happened out of nowhere
and it's a big question mark and YouTube
has given them no answers and you might
be thinking at home oh that's commodity
at YouTube that's a big organization
clearly they must have done something
wrong but speaking as people who have
been hit by this as well they are not
lying this is a real thing and we don't
usually go into behind-the-scenes
business stuff Ocoee fair it's not
professional it's a good thing to do but
this kind of affects you too so that's
one of the reasons we're talking about
this on January 5th at 8:57 p.m. we got
an email from YouTube saying that
monetization and other account features
have been disabled two hours later we
were finally able to get into our
account to see what apparently affected
us and we found out that we had a strike
from studio ghibli the Japanese company
not the American Disney part of it Japan
against my neighbor totoro the Disney
cember review of my neighbor totoro
which is completely in fair use which by
the way you can see on three separate
other YouTube channels right now they
haven't gotten it now you might be
thinking oh that must be the reason well
we've gotten strikes before in the past
I'm League of super critics we've gotten
to and we have never lost these features
before when you get one strike your
videos are limited down to 15 minutes
which is what's going on now but not
these other features so as of now with
just one strike the only features we can
use is thumbnails we can make custom
thumbnails and the wonderful YouTube
editor which I'm sure you all know how
fantastic that is so you might be
thinking maybe they change the rules on
strikes what they did they never told
anybody about it
so we went to YouTube's partner support
and we said what's going on here why
can't we not
our videos we've gotten strikes before
and we resolve them we are coming up on
three weeks with no answer from YouTube
whatsoever and if you look on their site
it says that they respond in 1 business
day
one business day now means three weeks
they forgot to tell you that but we're
letting you know this right now and
going it could be even longer than this
so okay what if it is a strike we can't
get a clear answer but we just want to
clear as much as we can so we tried to
go through the traditional route we try
to file the DMCA counterclaim which you
can do through YouTube every single time
we did this and we did this for like a
couple days we always got a server error
so then we had to contact YouTube to say
why are we getting a server error this
is a separate email from the one saying
why aren't we getting monetized they
sent us a form email again not able to
talk to a person and they said oh don't
use that route use these other means so
they're already acknowledging this route
doesn't work but whatever we have other
means one was a link that we can't use
because we have these limitations so the
same day we sent them an email the
manual way because they said that's one
of the ways you can do it and we put
that all the information they needed as
well as overnighted a physical letter to
them to make sure that this was getting
to them because that was also a way they
said would work both said we were
missing information and we looked over
it we followed it to a tee nothing was
missing so we had to think outside the
box because clearly this is making no
sense so we had two managers on the
YouTube account so one logged in to do
the way that we tried and then while the
other managers logged in the other
manager that logged in got a completely
different form like 100% different and
to make things even better they said
that the characters the amount of
letters you can put in has to be 250 you
can't go over that so you have pretty
much the length of a tweet to make your
legal case about why you're in the right
so the counter DMCA notice is in effect
after going through this incredibly
broken system but we have yet to talk to
a human being and we're coming up on
three weeks of getting no monetization
no money for any of the videos that
we've put out past and present all
videos we are making no money right now
the only way we've gotten any contact to
YouTube like a human being at all is
through contacts with other people and
even then nobody has given us a straight
answer
nothing has been consistent nobody knows
what's going on okay so this is the part
that concerns you we have over three
hundred fifty thousand subscribers on
YouTube we've been around for years if
this can happen to us with no
explanation no reason why and weeks of
no pay and no explaining any of it what
chance do people just putting up their
family videos have what chance do people
just starting off monetizing or trying
to make a living or whatever have
against this everything being done right
now is done through the algorithm there
is no human being looking over any of
this and it seems like the only way to
get attention and get them to do
something is to escalate it a lot of
youtubers are now making videos saying
this has happened and we don't know why
because they were trying to do the same
thing they were trying to go the
professional route of trying to talk to
YouTube trying to get answers and none
of them have been answered even the
channels that were lucky enough to be
put back if the channel is deleted and
put back or they weren't getting
monetization they were put back YouTube
has never explained what happened or
what they can do to not have this happen
in the future that is scary for years
we've put up with this idea that YouTube
makes it where you're guilty until
proven innocent and that's not just but
at least they made it clear these are
the rules these what you have to do and
we didn't like following them but it's
still in the grand scheme of things a
young business when you really look at
and so many changes are happening in
studio heads are trying to bully them so
they're making changes trying to figure
it out
fair enough but now nothing is making
sense rules are just being made up and
they're not being explained to us and
this is for anybody not just big
channels anyone could get taken down
these rules and everything were put in
place to stop people from running full
movies and pirating stuff and fair
enough that you need to do what you have
to do but now we're at a point where
it's just abuse people are not looking
at these anymore I mean they haven't
looked at them for a while but now
they're not even following their own
rules if you have any videos on you
right now make sure they're backed up
make sure you have them somewhere into
your computer because they can disappear
at any point and they don't have to tell
you why you know it companies make
mistakes and it's fine I mean the aware
company we make mistakes everybody does
but when you're doing this and you're
not doing anything to change it and
you're not explaining why you're pretty
much letting everybody know this is how
we do things and this is right this is
just we can do whatever we want if we
want to get rid of someone just showing
their family movies and we don't have to
explain why we can do it now and it's
totally ok if we want to take someone
who's making a living now on YouTube as
many people are and get rid of it and
get rid of their monetization or just
destroy their entire channel it is
totally fine with them and they don't
have to tell you why so that's the
reason you haven't seen any Steven
universe be logs or bum reviews uh
because we've been busy with this
we've gone almost three weeks with no
pay for any of our videos and in my
opinion until we get monetization back
on this channel and these other channels
our channels have been deleted or put
back or at least given an explanation or
just anything it's pretty much saying
YouTube can do whatever it wants and
we're okay with it just as we make money
off of YouTube YouTube makes money off
of us we were in a situation we were
forced to accept and we accepted it
because the rules were in place and they
seemed to follow it but now they're not
even following their own rules YouTube
support is non-existent right now right
now you need to be very cautious we
can't say how because even we don't know
how but you need to be very careful and
here's the thing anyone can change they
can come around and they can say hey
this mistake happened we're fixing it
and we're on top of it I mean anything
or here's the new rules and we'll do our
best to follow it we've been changing
our content a lot in order to fit
YouTube's rules and even doing that now
hasn't worked but we're not told why
because when I even told what the rules
are anymore
YouTube's system is not only broken but
it's made to be abused so we're still
getting to a nostalgia critic videos
because we know you guys
want to see those even though we're
making nothing at them right now we're
still gonna do them but stuff like the
Steven universe's and the bumper views
and the real thoughts instead that we
got a hold off until we figure this out
until we're allowed to make a living
again YouTube's system right now is run
on automation everything from small
complaints to stuff that can shut a
channel down no human being is looking
at them until it's escalated so that's
why we're forced to talk about this like
I said there's a whole mountain of other
issues that's going on with YouTube that
we can't talk about here because we only
have 15 minutes it we just want to keep
this focused and give you guys fair
warning what is going on with YouTube
right now and how your channel is at
risk
so hopefully this gets resolved
hopefully YouTube wakes up and starts
treating people and channels fair and
just again because their livelihoods are
depending on it now and you can't just
wait weeks and weeks with no answer when
people are now depending on this to make
a living we're gonna have links below to
other channels that are going through
similar issues right now because there's
quite a few we hope that this gets
resolved we hope that so may these
problems are going on with YouTube get
fixed but as of now we are forced to
deal with a broken system and this is
the best that we can do this is the best
we're allowed to do so guys that's about
it just an explanation of what's going
on and just be cautious be very very
cautious backup all your videos if you
have them on YouTube and just be very
very careful I'll talk to you guys later
take care